you
[Music]
so I'm really happy to bring the speaker
today Nick Hurd is a well an excellent
researcher but first and foremost he's a
he's a real good friend of mine and we
go back at least a 2011 which makes us
both of a certain age I think and that
you know that we met in true academic
style and that I was working on my
dissertation and I thought I had an
original idea I know many of you have
probably come across this where you
thought you had an original idea I did a
little bit of a literature review and it
turns out somebody beat me to it and it
turned out it was Nick and so I sent him
an email and said hey that's that's a
great idea I thought it was mine but
you're a smart guy for having it and
that that resulted in a long long term
collaboration we've got papers together
and patents and I've mentored his his
postdocs and students and I hope to
extend that relationship here at
Microsoft and do a lot of collaboration
with with Nick and Imperial College so
with that we're going to hear his views
on statistics and cybersecurity thanks
Nick
thanks Josh thank you for the very
generous introduction that's so it's not
quite as he tells of it it's very kind
very very kind of you to say that so
thank you for the invitation I'm
thrilled to be here to talk so the type
of my talk is statistics and
cybersecurity and so I'm a researcher
from operative mathematics at Imperial
College in London and also seconded out
to the Harbin Institute for mathematical
research so here's the obligatory slide
of people I've worked with in the work
here I'm looking forward to adding
Josh's name and Microsoft there the next
time I give this talk so the top line of
my graduate students working at Imperial
and then
Sylvia works at the ATI Val ensuring
institutes as a postdoc Pat's a friend
and collaborator at Bristol and Melissa
is a LAN all which and there'll be lots
of mentions of Los Alamos or LAN all for
shorts throughout the talk and
everything I have in terms of contact
with them which is all from Josh so I'm
very grateful to him for that
collaboration which has been a
long-lasting and very fruitful
collaboration so that's all due to Josh
okay so I probably don't need to plug
this point to you guys so much but
there's a general understanding I think
by government and industry that data
science techniques have some role to
play in the future of cyber security
defenses there's plenty of data sources
available that could help discover and
prevent Network attacks an imperial our
interests are in developing statistical
probability models for detecting well
for building models of normal behavior
and detecting intrusions by seeing if
there's outlying behavior with respect
to those models so and the advantage of
being able to do this is that we can
discover zero-day attacks by by looking
at people's normal behavior and looking
for unusual deviations from those so it
could even be someone using legitimate
credentials but they may be stolen
therefore traversing in an unusual way
so these are the different data sources
we look at Imperial most of the things
I'm going to talk about it's about
network flow data so this IP address
talk to this IP address on this protocol
and some other data particular the start
time is another thing I'll look at so
the timings of events but we also look
at other things as well so there's
authentication events so users
authenticate in fed to getting on
computers whether or not they're
successful and what time that happened a
bit of host based stuff so the events
and process that's much more along the
lines of you guys probably look at so
that's the space was just starting to
work into a bit of that and there's also
potential to do some physical type stuff
like there's building access control IOT
and so on
so a lot of the models I want to add a
fairly simple we only think about high
frequency data and I want to do thinning
so it's a screening in triage they like
finding the interesting stuff amongst
the bulk of traffic we have passing
through our network
we want models that can be used in
Hadoop if we can and things that's the
constraint so there's lots of different
ways we could think about analyzing our
cyber data and this loss a different
approach and a folk focus on these three
different ones so you can think of these
as heading down from the map from the
macroscale at the top down to a micro
stay together who work down that
bulleted list so I could look at sort of
network wide view of my view of my
network and perhaps you things like
graph theory spectral decomposition x'
community detection and clustering and
also some high-level summaries for
network oversight I'm going to do these
in the reverse order in the talk so I'll
do start with edge first but yeah so we
can look at network level we look at
node based models and build models of
the process a user or a computer runs
its connectivity its pattern of life
time it's active or you go right down to
edge based models it's looking for safer
beacons just specifically IP addresses
some temporal dependence between edges
and typical packet sizes and things like
that so all at the point is that all of
these could use useful cyber analytics
and it's not a competition we can look
at all of these and getting come up with
analytics and run them all in parallel
and gathering together is where we think
we can gain strength so we will have a
whole bunch of analytics running and
somehow try to combine them all so
hopefully getting a lot bunch of weak
indicators and combining them into
something strong that's the idea so we
want to have lots of different views of
the problem and combine them so yeah
this talk is going to go be a sort of
summary of some of the work we've been
doing in this area sand publish stuff
some stuff already done and the stuff
already with we're currently doing now
so starting from the most micro level
look edges so an edge by an edge by
between two IP addresses say I mean to
say the edge I have an edge between x
and y what I mean is that X has ever
been observed to initiate a connection
to Y so I'm gonna feel about directed
edges all my graphs going to be directed
over an arrow on my links between nodes
so a node will be an IP address and yeah
you think of the edge as being this of
the fundamental the primitive if you
like of doing cybersecurity data
analysis it's not a node instead of
counterintuitive a and noting like this
is obvious fundamental where's actually
from this observing traffic the edge is
the primitive the know
is the union of all the ages coming from
it so the edge is this with the building
block if you like for all all our models
so that's the the most micro level we
can look at is a specific age their
traffic from this IP address to this IP
address okay so in NetFlow juicers will
say what most of this talk is will be
about some some ages will carry entirely
automated traffic some will carry human
just human traffic and some would carry
a combination of the two okay so one to
look at first it's how we go about
classifying edges as being either human
or automated if we don't know anything
about our network a priori so one simple
diagnostic you'd have is that automated
edges typically carry what I would call
superhuman levels of traffic volume so
you could just threshold on that you say
okay there's way more than a human could
generate in that day so that's got to be
automated so you could just do that and
I want to hold hands up about that but
is that that's not always the case and
so what we want is some more
sophisticated filters besides just
threshold on volume to say that's an
automated edge that contains some
automated traffic so they're often
automated stuff is often highly periodic
corresponding to beacons for updates or
keeper lives so we have a paper we did
in 2014 where we scan for periodicity x'
in the data coming from an a coming on a
single edge and so we looked at the pier
at a gram after some observation time T
which could be efficiently calculated
using the fast Fourier transform so I'm
going to explain a bit about what this
formula does in a second that second is
now so f hat of F this pirata gram is if
this effectively its proportion to the
squared magnitude of the resultant
vector if I put all over each event onto
the unit circle as unit vectors on the F
to the minus one second clock so that is
if I think about a particular frequency
F I can imagine a clock of circumference
one over F and I just stop the clock
going and work my ran down and as events
go as it occur I'm gonna just drop a
mark down and keep on going around
dropping marks down as the events are
that's what this does forget this but
this is uninteresting that's just a
constant as it were these increments of
the process have been more
blind by this guy here and that's
essentially just plotting points down
onto the circle in this way so just
backing off for a second what we want to
do is find surprisingly high levels of a
periodicity at specific frequency or
equals are going to find them at so when
I look at a bunch of frequencies and
calculate this function here and see if
there's any clustering of these points
on these circles for a gift for any
given F that's that's the game it
doesn't exist such a frequency such that
the points are all bunched up I put them
onto an F after the minus 1 o'clock so
this is what my s hat of F looks like
from my own computers connections to
Dropbox ok so you can see a peak at
around the 55 second mark okay and so
there are the event times projected on
to such a clock onto Anto yeah a 55
second clock so you can see there's some
bunching but there's two sets of
bunching that's ok there's been some
sort of refresh at some point where
they're all beaconing at one phase and
then there was perhaps a delay or reboot
or something and then beaconing again at
a slightly it's still at the same
periodicity but a phase shift but that's
ok if you look at the resultant vector
those are still on the same scale those
blue points or as massive resultant
vector of adding that just adding all
those unit vectors together whereas if I
just pick some other arbitrary period so
43 was a number that came to my head and
try putting that in so that's them
projecting for 43 second copy you can
see them all just rather more uniformly
scattered there's still a bit of
bunching because that's normal you do
get multiple pulses for a single sort of
event and you can sequence you tend to
get a bit of blurring and multiple
events and so on so I get a non-zero
resultant vector but nowhere near of the
same magnitude so that's the point so
that's what's driving this spike in s
hat of F it's that there is that
fantastic bunching at that specific
frequency
you know a nanosecond and 23 weeks or
like yeah well we only have dates
recorded to the millisecond so I'm never
going to find anything you know yeah
yeah yes yeah yeah like a few seconds is
common that's possible yeah whereas if I
go to you big then I get 86400 seconds I
a day and that's just human again so I'm
kind of interested in in periods of gel
or less somewhat less than that okay so
that's just to see what it looks like so
that's what if I looked at all the
traffic coming from my computer the
left-hand image shows a sort of time of
day histogram plot of when when my
computer does its business and you can
see I've got this is a big spike of
activity at 2:00 a.m. which isn't I
hopefully embed some of the time so
that's not that's not me and you can see
that or get sort of taken out if I
filter out by doing this sort of
processing so 80% or more of my traffic
was was easily found to be automated by
just doing this sort of filtering with
really significant p-values on this test
which I didn't really say about this
Fisher's test using this statistic the
maximum of that function divided by the
sum of the things okay
sum over all frequencies I want to find
I specifically a ivories end using a
simple central limit theorem arguments
under the assumption of a null model of
a homogeneous press on process these
things would because grade under the
null that's easy to work that out and so
you can get close for them or
approximations to the p-values really
easily so you can actually quantify
these things so that stuff we've done a
few years ago so that's out there and
that's kind of a handy technique so
that's our sort of first go to think in
terms of call classifying an edge but
you can see even in the drop box picture
there are still a few a few edges events
that don't sort of fit in with the
bunching and it's kind of interesting to
think about mixtures where perhaps I've
got some human things as well as butts
I've changed a file there or whatever
there could be some some human mixed in
with suppose you'll still get it because
even though I've got an edge which has a
mixture of human and odd has made it
high
well I know this computer it's mine
so it's probably one person yeah that's
a great question there'll be a bit later
on in the talk we'll talk about mixtures
of individuals and so that would be a
but I'm not being scripted about that I
just want to know is it water made it
clear a periodic or is it something else
yeah that's a fair question
I'll come back to it so yeah if I've got
this if I've got a mixture of human and
automated stuff the automated traffic is
always high volumes that will dominate
so I will get to say okay there is
periodic there is a periodicity going on
on this age but there could be a mixture
and so what what current work is doing
with Francesco is looking at looking too
deep to separate out patterns and
classify every single event and say
whether each every single NetFlow event
is automated or human so for examples I
was - there's two ways in one is I can
look at these clocks if this is my this
is the frequency I've found I can say
okay well this event here that's not
it's not in it's not in phase with the
rest of the beacon so this is a somewhat
of an outlier from that so that's one
indicator of that being perhaps a human
event is it's not in with the bunched
events of the periodic signal that I'm
looking for okay so that's one piece of
evidence is it in is it in phase with
the beacons and the second thing is what
time of day did it happen is it in the
middle of the day or is it during the
nighttime there's a - so you're thorgan
all pieces of information which I can
bring together to do inference on a on
an event by event basis yeah saying that
they're so briefly what we're doing then
we're looking at Bayesian mixture model
to learn the human and automated
components of this mixture density that
we think might be going on on a given
edge so if I cause FA the density for
automated events and FH the density for
human ones I want to learn those two
things so just for simplicity so when
lots and lots of simple simple stats
models us we want to do these things at
scale so we fit a wrapped normal
distribution
on the unit circle so we rescale
everything once we know our inferred
frequency from the Fisher's test we can
be scared we can rescale everything to
the unit circle and put it on north of
two pi so we have an automated density
FA for learning we're learning the mean
essentially what's the phase perhaps
that should be a mixture distribution
we've got multiple phases but the
moments just a single one and for this
example that's fine and we learn the
variance of these beacons so we want to
learn the mean the red so what's the
phase shift and what's the REC what's
the blurring it's always plus or minus a
bit of time that's never bang on so I
want to learn that for the automated
part and for the human thing we want to
learn the day time essentially so it
hopefully has some sort of structure
like that so for that we have a step
function density so IC which is
piecewise constant density with an
unknown number of steps this is a
particular hormone I just love piecewise
constant things are really easy and
tractable to work with and they are
consistent you know if I don't bound the
number of steps then asymptotic news I
get more and more data I will find the
density so fantastic flexible forms so
so that's what we use that for the
density for for the human stuff coming
yeah so this is working progress so
these are taken from the draft paper
which Francesca is waiting for me to
read
so you'll be glad to hear this question
being asked to get on with it
yeah so that's that's the beaconing
stuff so that's all work in terms of
separating out automated from human now
moving on to human stuff we were to
think about the coax the automated stuff
is kind of easy to understand it's
periodic and that's okay but we want to
build models of the human stuff better
as well so even human generated network
connections don't arrive as a person
process they're coming bunches is so
kind of bursty which Josh opened my eyes
to when I first met him in 2011 so that
was a big big blows we've been doing
loads of stuff with profs and processes
mathematicians like press and prices
they're fantastically tractable easy to
work with they're lovely models to work
with but if they don't hold it's just
going to give us the wrong inference so
with Matt and other my graduate students
we're looking at trying to model
self-excitation
so looking at the counting process of
events on an edge which we've considered
to be human and still trying to learn
what
sort of self-excitation that goes on so
the modern we've arrived upon it this
sort of nonparametric world process
structure I've included a diagram below
which is misleading because this is the
only relevant one these are just other
models we look at in the paper so
socially what's going on is I'm saying
essentially my why is my event price my
counting price of events for this edge
of interest then I have some background
intensity lambda and then some
triggering effect here so if these my
event times then I look at how long it's
been since the last event t minus y of Y
of T it says how long has it been since
the last event and these lambda J is
going to be some decreasing sequence
with again an unknown number of change
once I'm getting piecewise constant or a
with a but with a decreasing intensity
going to back down until the vegetate
goes back down to the bay the background
and again asymptotically we should learn
the correct intensity if it's the right
model in terms of structure and we
should learn it so people tend to work
with Hawkes process when people are
doing self exciting models of point
processes so there you add up every time
you have a debate you get a boost like
an exponential star boost so that's
what's drawn here so every time I have
an event these X's red crosses I get a
boost in the intensity so we looked at
those models we looked at wold with the
world processes again which that just
says how long since the last event
rather than accumulating because that's
the thing so I think with this guy you
just get too much because net flow is so
bursty there's massive boost that meant
something doesn't happen the models in a
bit of shop you've finally stopped so
the world model seemed to fit better and
this exponential isn't quite right it's
a bit we can fit more flexible things
obviously this doesn't look so flexible
in this pitch but asymptotically you say
we can fit however many steps we need
perfectly in the end so this proves to
be the best model in terms of fitting
the excitation that happens within the
process so it's a flexible model and it
provides us a consistent estimator the
asymptotic people get it right it
captures burstiness and in by capturing
persons we found it negates the need to
fit a model for seasonality because
actually be the obviously it was a human
age my intensity function should have
some preponed over what time of day is
it it was the night time I really should
be concerned about that but
we found the burstiness is enough you
know people don't leave well at the same
time every day so fitting seasonal
models is something I'm starting to go
off we've done that quite a bit but it
it's such a to do it well you'd have to
have a really flexible structure on top
of that there's a lot of a lot of a lot
of work involved in doing that and we
found for the simple models we were
looking at field building in time of day
this was just swallowing everything up
you know if I've just done no Ventus now
I'm still at work and at the moment I've
stopped then maps it's okay and so we
kind of yeah in terms of keeping a
million bottles around Ramada monitoring
all the customers we have to keep these
models for each each users say then we
have to have all these parameters for
the time of day right and so it gets
expensive
computing yeah yeah so you can see yet
see the performance and so blue is her
motions process if we did our best fit
of a homogeneous Poisson process of the
data this is a this is a QQ plot yes we
want to have a 45-degree line for just
trying to imagine the data much as
possible as I get the blue line the red
is an inhomogeneous Poisson process
where I've tried to learn the time of
day intensity and barely get any uplift
at all from doing that whereas the self
exciting models do particularly well and
this is why the black line is the world
one with the nonparametric intensity and
that's one which is doing best which is
why we favored it so I think it's
incredible performance that means it's
not my work it's mat so I can say that I
believe we can fit that so well this is
just predicting when the next event is
going to be so yeah that seemed that's
interesting stuff so that sage is dealt
with not there fully covered but that's
all that's all we've done on edges so
next up notes so one level higher up in
there in there in there in this sense of
granularity so we've done some modeling
of destinations of nodes so looking at
the sequence of IP addresses say a
computer connects to really related some
work I did with Josh on poor scoring a
long time ago so it's kind of the same
model again so here we think about sort
of scoring every single event so look at
the note as
it connects to overtime and scoring the
surprise of every single Ezio you've
connected to that one and so on so
really simple things and and then
aggregated surprised using control
charts or p-value combined as I'm big
into any value combined as these days
which is quite odd it's a Bayesian but I
correlate them anyway so in 2016 we've
got a paper where we looked at modeling
from a server-based perspective so I
look at a server and it has its own
model of okay who's going to connect me
next I have a probability mass function
on the go of who I think which learns
over time who I think is going to
connect to me next so we look at the
sequence of clients x1 x2 it's all which
connect to a server why when you simply
model as a multinomial so nothing clever
going on at all with an unbounded number
of categories that makes it a bit more
interesting so imagine I don't know how
the limit of my computer network they
could be arbitrarily many computers I
don't want to see I want to but I can
think about having a base measure on the
names of my computer so I think is quite
a fun thought and some measure of
confidence in that alpha and then from
that just in that simple to reshape
process model with a multinomial we get
a p-value for every simple observation
so you can think of Alpha X star is the
measure attached to observing the next
event being on X so you get a chunk of
probability from the base measure and
then it's essentially glorified
histogram a count of how many times I've
seen this this client connect before
along with the base measure so really
simple things so to score an edge first
of all we just looked at all the
connections from from a unique from each
unique client to the server Y and found
the minimum p-value of that and that
should follow a beta distribution up to
some approximations at least assuming
independence and continuity and so on
and being beautiful not one and not
discrete and we transform those two
p-values we get an edge score a p-value
of every edge and so then from a node
perspective what we were to do is then
combine all those if I look at line
clients I want to say okay what was the
peeve at what was the p value at all for
each of your edges so for a computer
here which turned out to or the more
interesting ones is it from the los
alamos network data
this is the p-values we got for all its
edges so loads of surprise going on so
this was one of the red team attack
notes this guy here so it was really
easy to find I mean those dates are so
easy assess there's no great glory in
winning this but it's just a nice
demonstration of how we can do simple
models and get well calibrated decent
answers out in an automated fashion so
yeah we use fish is measured to combine
to get an old score in the end and those
are fairly RPG choices if a combine is
so a lot of my work since then has been
looking at how you choose a proper piece
and make a proper choice a p-value
combiner so I've done a paper on that it
is a camera and biometrika this year so
more interesting the that's okay that's
fine I can look at just my surprised at
going to edges that I've been to before
or not and so on but really we were most
interested in new edges so for node
formed new edges I want to think how
surprising that is okay so in the red
team attacking the landlord data there
was a lot of hole bursts of new New Age
activity created by the red team and
that should be an easy way of detecting
unusual behavior so what we want to do
is sort of understand whether new edge
activity is odd for that host because
the point is that different hosts form
new edges at very different rates some
make lots of new edges and some are much
more consistent in the notes that they
visit so there are different rates
between between hosts and also we want
to think about who they are who they are
just being informed with if it's a new
edge okay well who to is that and is
that the sort of node you ought to be
connecting to or is it the sort of node
someone else should be connecting to so
we want to understand yeah what's the
right sort of node for you to be
connecting to as well as understand the
rate at which you should be forming
those things so we're looking at
building models of these things so again
we look at this as a County res we look
at the counting process of new edges
being formed okay so for every so if
capital X are my sources and my clients
and capital y are my servers and
destinations we want to model the new
edge intensity lambda X Y
tea for a pair of for a client/server
pair XY so it's a new edge intensity so
if GT is my current graph at time T of
all the edges have ever seen that I've
got indicator saying if if it I need it
to be insight and need not to be in GT
so it's in X cross Y /g t so it needs to
have not been seen otherwise this
indicates there's a zero I've got no
intensity of a new edge there if I've
already seen it so that's all that first
bit is saying make sense
then there'll be some seasonality
function which I'm going to treat as a
nuisance parameter and not do inference
on that sort of the recurring theme and
this we're just not doing that that much
seasonality modeling that's all and then
some other covariance which had to do
with the degree the out degree of X the
in degree of Y so how much they make new
edges whether they're in a burst of
activity so this is an indicator it's
equal to one if my last edge I met each
was a new one and this is equal to one
if the last two edges I connected on one
knew that further term didn't make any
difference in stuff we did to those
those two neither the covariance of
whether or not I'm in a burst of making
edges that's a good pretty sure what I'm
about to make another plus some
mysterious last final term of some
latent variable which is going to
characterize the attractions EDX where I
was going to catalyze the attraction
from X to Y in some model that we're
going to build so we had two versions of
doing that one is a hard thresholding
clustering model so we cluster clients
and serves and have like a bit like a
stochastic blob model or say this type
of client connects to this group of
servers that's a good fit so we cluster
up the clients and servers into blocks
and say okay well that block does tend
to connect to that block so you and then
that's okay or that some more unusual or
we do something more soft and do a
latent feature model with an Indian
buffer process prior and started trying
to do the much more flexible style of
modeling which is and that actually
turns out to do better so that's a paper
which is under review at the moment so
it's work we've done but it's my honor
yeah yeah that turns out to be the best
thing for we did
his here's a picture just to illustrate
that in action so these are the p-values
that we obtained for two computers this
is what that in fact same affected one
again looking at now from a new-age
perspective and just some other random
ish an infected and computer and LS
anomaly so these are control chart
associates have combined p-value
functions over time and here at various
p-value thresholds drawn on and ways to
work out by Monte Carlo what they should
be to calibrate these things because
some have more events than others and so
on but on a p-value scale these are now
the same and you can see that here we go
way down in low p-values in in terms of
the new edges we're making here whereas
for the onion affected one it makes new
edges but they're they're okay they're
not surprising either by rate or by who
they're with and so on so notice and
that's it in action learning over time
or as a time-varying covariance so I
think why we did it was we have to read
data in in chunks and update the model
over time and it's an seems to work out
either way reading all the data in is a
bit problematic for us and fitting this
model so we tend to just take a subset
and just learn and everything pretty
small stuff and so on so I think so
Sylvia mattelli of them all the all the
hard work for that so she'd be the
person to HP to say no it's not yes it
is we could be your so that's quite a
nice general this sort of new edges or
unlikely edges a nice general contract
we can look at different things we can't
surprise in the sequence of processes
executed by computer and measure the
accumulator surprising in those or in
data fusion combining host processes and
network level things and sort of getting
getting scores for each of those things
that's current we're we're doing under
the data centric engineering program ATI
and with Josh in the past we've looked
at ports going
modeling how unlikely using different
services is say lots of applications of
you for such simple models insider and
then finally a whole graph perspective
am i do for time pages so yes this is a
very sort of highest that we could think
about taking so this is joint work with
with Pat Pat and Francesco so here yeah
we want to look it look at the full
graph and look at and look a few if we
can learn underlying structure in the
graph and so we're going to consider a
binary adjacency matrix and look about
counts just yet
think about the binary directed
adjacency matrix eighty-four my entire
network such that a T IJ is equal to one
if and only if I is connected to J which
I'll write it that way by time T so
here's just a cartoon graph of what G of
T looks high perhaps that one's
connected to two and two hasn't
connected to three and so on and look at
that binary representation of the haveta
of that graph so it's the adjacency
matrix that I'm talking about so yeah a
low-rank approximation of this thing so
this is what I've observed up to time T
if I take a low-rank approximation of a
TS such as or some of the platen style
transformation of a T as well it could
be that that can provide it's a bit like
building a statistical model if I take a
low-rank approximation to prevent
overfitting if they taking a low-rank if
I take a full SVD I just recover the
full matrix again I don't have a model I
just saying okay I've seen this in your
site if I've seen it then it's what
happens with probably one and if I
haven't happens of the property zero so
that's my good where like a low-rank
approximation of that thing and and do
some can be difficult seek outside it
was negative and greater than one
something to do some sensible sort of
treatment of that estimate of a of T you
can think of that as being like a model
being like a prediction so we can do is
prop we can do estimation and prediction
using this thing so yeah we think about
SVD a lot so a is approximately a hat of
K in the sense that if I do SVD and get
a head of K that's the closest K
dimensional rank K approximation of a in
the Frobenius
gnorm essentially that gives me two
matrices of vectors in k dimensional
space so that I'm thinking about clients
and servers say every client and every
server each gets a position in k
dimensional space and even if those are
the same computer they'll still get a 1
positioning client space of one position
in server space it's the way we treated
it so the eyes or Jeff row of UK or VK
respectively provided a notional later
position in K dimensional space for that
client or server and so pretty pointless
picture but I guess what I'm interested
in is so being able to look at the
jacimo issues this is an observed make
the adjacency matrix which you know have
mostly zeros with the occasional ones
scattered around and what I want to do
is find that unlikely one that one which
service glares out the picture that
shouldn't be there compared to the rest
of the structure of the graph this
little game we want to play either in
prediction for the future or just
looking at my graph saying oh that's it
that one shouldn't be there that's the
game so some work we've done in that
direction was with Melissa from lanlan
Francesco is now carrying on that work
where we actually looked at the non
binary version where rather than just
ones and zeros in this this thing
instead in the IH eighth position I've
got the number of connections I've seen
up to time T so 0 if I'd never seen it
but otherwise some non-negative integer
positive integer if I've seen the edge
so so byte 8 is it's a bit of a decision
why do you think is informative to see
how many times that collides is
connected to a server I mean some heads
there might be overkill in that signal
but on the other hand you're getting
some sort of sense of preference and
they'll no edges are equal and if I go
to this edge this this this server a lot
then perhaps that's an important server
to me and I want to think of it as a
recommender system type problem where
this sort of client really likes that
sort of server so this that works is
taking that that approach so we have a
oppress OnStar model so my a Jason C is
no count so river press and star stretch
but again this
product idea of latent positions for the
both the client and the server or in
this case user and process or user and
computer the same ideas and there were
some sort of clever prior structure
something we sort of shared some of its
information between edges for the same
user or for the same same service we get
the idea of busyness like this user does
a lot or this server gets a lot of
traffic and so you have some sharing
between between ages so that's not
completely free so we had a p-value for
anomaly detection given by the upper
tail probability of the cam you see like
how fancy getting as many as we did
given this Poisson model and then use
Fisher's method simply to before to
combine it is to get a score for users
your clients
whereas now we're currently extending
this work just with Josh and this team
earlier about about incorporating known
groupings of computers and users with on
lonely ladies and feta so I could know
something about particularly users say
okay this user is in this department and
so on and so therefore there should be
some natural grouping and some
similarity so I'm trying to find network
structure and if I already know some
information about that I should be
putting that into that model arguably so
we're looking at how to build those
things in this further factors in this
model but it's the same framework now to
revisit the question so I was asked the
question earlier about and make whether
I've got more than one user human use on
on a single ad which certainly as an
option I'm interested in in so we can
think about the network traffic flowing
from an IP address as being a mixture of
multiple individuals each exhibiting
their own make mixtures of behavioral
norms so I can think of the traffic
coming for an IP address as a like a
mixture of mixtures even so it could be
different users like a family of users
all using the same ip address and within
that different devices like any I have T
star thing they could be all different
sort of physical devices keep making
network connections and also computers
and their other things so all sorts of
men different tasks as well so all sorts
of different mixtures you can think
about going on so generally I want to
think about mixtures or mixtures of
mixtures of behaviors and
I find a very interesting research from
really hard to think that could is it
possible to actually detangle that
mixture is if I observe an IP address
for long enough could I infer how many
people are using it what which devices
which types at which which which which
uses active at different times which
behaviors they're armed when they are
active and so on those things that feel
they should be eventually observable
because if it's taking the user example
that they won't all being active all the
time they'll sort of come and go and so
if you could see the repeated structure
temporarily come and go over time in
principle it should be possible to
detangle that and say okay I can see
those sort of connections happen in
blocks of time and they stop and they
come and go so this should be possibly
tangle but it's really a really awkward
inference problem so yeah I see this is
like a sort of topic modeling problem
the idea if we can do that it's great
because we could build better models if
I could say actually this isn't just a
single homogeneous thing this is
actually a mixture of lots of different
things and if I could understand what
those things are then I've been a much
better place to build good models so
yeah we see as a topic modeling so that
is this of idea in text analysis where I
take us with corpus of documents and
count how many times word appears as a
bag of words representation and think
okay
each topic each document is made up of a
mixture of topics and those topics have
distributions on words as the usual
lining so either it's about cats or it's
about microwaves or whatever and
there'll be a different lexicon of words
that are used for each of those
different topics but a priori we don't
know what the topics are or their word
distributions we don't know anything but
people still try to do that and try and
infer what the topics are automatically
they try to draw them out so that's a
very active research area in computer
science as well as statistics so yeah we
see it as analogous problem in cyber and
say if you look at the traffic from from
an IP address or a user then we could
think about yes I think about an IP
address then the topics could be a user
so the different you the different users
could be each we thing of it seen as
being like a topic or their behaviour
could be seen as a topic and the in the
IP address of those users or behaviors
visit would be like the documents no
sorry
they're telling us oh those are the
topics and the documents would be like a
chunk of time of say one day of traffic
so yeah we've done some work on that so
we did some initial very very low-level
efforts at that which is which is there
but there was a very easy problem in
trying to scale this up it's really hard
being the proper nonparametric is the
standard way of looking at these topic
models and they allow potentially
infinitely many temporarily occurring
and maybe even temp time varying topics
there's so much you could do with this
sort of stuff so this is joint work with
jinwu Zhang and none of my PhD students
and she's doing really well I think
consider this is an example data set
we're looking at this is a real data
again from Lana so we have s right so
each row is a day of data so it's ten
days of data and these are 32 different
computers being connected to so and each
block corresponds to a true user so this
is user 1 user 2 user three years or
four years of five and this is how and
the colors show how much they connected
to each of these computers on on each of
the ten days so what we do is then take
those data and smash them together just
like difficult for ourselves if we can
unpick it again that's that's again can
we sort of infer just by putting some
sort of ideas of sparsity we think you
know they shouldn't we don't want topics
which visit all the computers here we
want to have some some idea okay there's
some sort of purity of these topic so if
I have a fixed behavior or usually they
don't they don't visit all that because
they have their favorites and they go to
those and we want so we push that into
the models we have ideas of sparsity and
some sort of temporal dependents are
there there should be some link over
times that you see the contiguous blocks
of connectivity as we push that into the
model as well so we're still getting
stuff around but it's great we're
getting some recovery of some of the
sort of shapes here so Genie is never
happy with this which I think they're
not bad we're not there yet but if
you're sort of starting to be able to
untangle that without knowing anything
trying to untangle the mixture
up to the viewer to decide whether
everything that's good or bad but I
think once once you mad okay yes I think
that's on the difficulty scale I think
that's the hardest thing we work on
because I think that's just real scale I
think it's gonna be really problematic
and finally I'm going to talk for with a
bit more length about some stuff I'm
doing when change detection so so this
is work with MSE student called Carl
who's starting it as a graduate student
in October so you're looking at this
stuff too it's also some work I'm doing
by myself on change point of notice I'm
gonna enjoy talking about that for the
end of this talk it's my current
favorite thing so finally it just first
an overall look at our nobody said no
side of the graph and so on it's just
kind of just did this look at traffic
volumes to see okay from Imperial or
landlord over your data is there an
unusual spike in a particular port or
from particular packet size or something
is there is there some thing we just
getting different account everything
that's gonna count everything going
through our our network is it is there
something useful going on in those
counts that's kind of feel like we want
to be able to do that it's the most
basic to take to think we should have on
the go we should be have some
situational awareness about going on and
so the motivating problem if you like is
one a cry okay so these are these are
our data for the whole of 2017 so this
is from Imperials Network these are the
counts of the number of net flow events
recorded on the three most common
commonly observed ports over 2017 port
four four five port 443 in broad eighty
so for four or five years of the new kid
on the block in this graph in as it
wasn't wasn't the most popular until
just before May 2017 which was of course
the time of the wanna cry attack which
is the biggest cyberattack to hit the UK
so far at least
infecting the NHS and various industry
and academia institutions although
Imperial hasn't been listed as one of
them but have certain we've seen an
incredible peat spike in four four five
at that
time and we ought to know about that we
shouldn't just be seeing us on Twitter
or something we ought to have seen even
here right I mean something's really
happening there we didn't have to wait
till the actuals of outbreak thing to
know that there was a gradual sort of
uprising of the use of peopie maybe
there's a legitimate reasons which we
ought to at least have some some
situational awareness of these sort of
things going on before sky I mean we
still if we're not counting things we
still don't even know
although networks working fine we don't
really don't really know so that's kind
of the motivating picture so I want to
find Peaks like that okay but it's not
just support so it's could be for
services but it could be other things
like traffic volumes or data volumes or
geo locations that I've got more traffic
connecting to IP addresses in location X
or something oh there's a lot of
different things I might want to count
and I know you don't want to put a limit
on that so I like to be the account lots
of different things and model them in a
nice effect in a flexible way and and
look for change points so this is a
graph of cars made it was very pretty
looking at just a week of data for
Imperials Network looking at different
ports and these are some change points
he's fitted so he's an MSC students is
excellent stuff to have done this so
Bayesian change point analysis on this
multinomial x' and so one is nice it's
nice pictures and you can sort of see
why change points are happiness one so
he's looking at both changes in volumes
and changes in the mixture so he's doing
us a marked change point thing when we
look to say okay there's a change point
and it's a change in the mixture if the
change in the volume or it's a change in
both so we classify the turns think the
chief was come with marks and we fit
that marker change point make sure of
course yeah so what this of what the
various
frequented frequencies are and then
there's the overall height of the bar is
is the volume so we're looking for
changes in so because this sort of way
of encoding so plus I think is a gain in
volume X is a change in what so is it
plus as a change in volume and X as a
change in mixture probability and the
star is those two on top so both of
those things so that's nice and you sort
of you look at the
doesn't make sense but the other take
away from me is that I've got awful lots
of change points I don't really want to
be getting that alarmed that often this
one week god everything's changed and
it's changed again you know so there's
only a certain level of amount of
surprise I'm willing to swallow and this
is this yes that this wretched
seasonality problem and human behaviour
so annoying everyone would just do the
same thing all the time just not go to
bed and not change the clocks or
anything just do everything cause
everything be so much easier but the the
insist on having varied lives and and
going to bed and all sorts so and and
for looking at ports that that manifests
itself in very different ways for
different ports so you can see port for
four three oh god this is so this is
pretty one a cry of other crises and
messes things up even more even look at
seasonality pre that in 2017 really big
sort of wheat day spikes for for port
443 less so for port 445 and so on more
popular ports yeah so there's all that
sort of level of variation going on all
the time so if you've got these
relatively different changes than if I
just start looking at those multinomial
yeah I'm gonna keep saying oh god
suddenly it suddenly you're full for
fees really popular I know now it's not
again and so on he's constantly
surprised over and over and I don't want
to get involved in modeling seasonality
as I've said because no two weeks are
the same and there's always a there's
gradual drifts going on over time I
can't just look at last week it's not
the same and there's all sorts of
different things going on so yeah I'm
going off fitting fitting seasonality
function is tight trying to build robust
models that you can just say okay let's
just not get it excited too often so yet
change point models so the idea of a
change point model is is we rely on
we're trying to partition up we look
over time was looking through time
observing a stream of data so just chop
it up into segments chop the the past
passage of time into segments and we
tend to fit really simple models within
each segment and then therefore when
I've fitted these piecewise in segments
then the overall global model is
therefore somewhat more complex because
I've been able to fit a local model and
I learn where to fit the cuts and so
so it's a way of they're essentially a
way of building a complex model with
lots of little ones to concatenated
together and often the model we fit is
an oversimplification and so we get more
change points than would be preferable
like in the figure I showed you so I say
you can model the seasonality and that's
that's certainly one alternative but say
no two weeks are often the same and
building the models isn't paper
intensive as well so just an extra
modeling problem to have to face
whenever I want to count anything
because they don't vary in the same way
each time so so this is just work I'm
doing by myself this is looking at
modeling data we've changed my segments
where I'm going to admit the models
probably misspecified and look for clear
discontinuity for a change when rather
than a gradual drift so this might look
like a bit of a hack and it may be it is
but I'm kind of really enjoying working
on its own and I'll tell you about it to
finish my talk so a quick review of
Bayesian change point analysis so towers
in my vector of change point so it's
unbounded it dates sequencer going on
forever so I'm going to learn a sequence
of change points tau tau want a to that
of increasing in time change points
which are unknown and they correspond to
the change points of a piecewise
deterministic process theater of T so my
parameter of my model is gonna be called
generic e theta and it varies over every
single time step but it's constant
within any segment so for for two
neighboring chain points for any T
within that this piecewise determine
improve the process theta T takes value
theta J so it's just a fancy way of
saying I have this parameter the changes
at every change point
okay so theta J is the parameter for the
J segment okay
and so the usual thing is for Bayesian
we have a price on process on the prior
for the change points then we try and
learn them given the data so suppose I
observe I'm going to think about
discrete time but actually what I'm
gonna tell me actually what's in
continuous time which is really nice but
I'm not gonna talk about that I'm gonna
talk about discrete time
I'm gonna serve a sequence X 1 X 2 dot
alive see it makes sense there could be
these counts of multinomial Council
whatever they just some some data-driven
thing and I have got a model P of XT
given theatres of T okay
my feature of T is give me one of these
piecewise deterministic processes so
baby Bayesian inference on towers is
particularly tractable and durable if I
assume conjugate independent prize for
the parameters theta J okay or price
which you can at least be well
approximated by those conjugate and
independent prize which case I can use
the conjugate prior and then do some
important sampling and everything works
out fine so so we tend to like looking
at conjugate prize when we can get away
with that because then those preamps can
be integrated out and we obtain a
marginal likelihood for all the data
we've observed
given the change points which typically
factorizes there are example like what's
a regressive process and where this
isn't the case but typically or they
have a factorization of so this is a
product over segments K of the data the
marginal distribution of the data within
that segment okay product over segments
of the property of either the data
within each segment this is something
raff there were integrated out feeds are
out so I've got a for each segment so I
just got a marginal just marginal
likelihood for those observations within
each segment and then take a product
over that segments and I'm done so
that's that's the thing we're normally
normally interested in working with so
that's very standard so here's an
example to make it concrete so suppose
within a segments I've got a gamma
distributed rate so these feature which
is 17 for a single segments imagine the
feet are one for the say the first
segment it follows a gamma distribution
and then within the segment if I suppose
I've got n things in the segment then x1
up to xn I seem to be iid press on theta
one that's typical so nice conjugate
prior for theta that's a typical
Bayesian model for the first segment of
a change point model okay so it's the
conjugate prior and I can integrate
these around get a margin like your x1
up to X n so the first I think
interesting non-intuitive observation to
make about this frameworks I draw a
single theta and then draw x1 up to X n
iid from press-on
Peter so I think interestingly insightly
paradoxically this Sampey scheme is
equivalent to the following dynamic
theater strategy so here I've got the
same theater for the whole of the
segments and that's how I described it a
piecewise deterministic process but
actually in terms of likelihoods in
terms of the genitive scheme for the x's
this is equivalent just draw draw three
to one again from gamma a B and just
draw X 1 from Praslin theta 1 then I
redraw a new theta from the posterior
what would be the posterior of theta
given X 1 that's what that looks like
and then draw X 2 from cross on theta 2
dot
eventually drawing the terrain from that
posterior and the neck sin from
Prasanthi terrain that gives the same
joint distribution of x1 up to xn as
this which i think is really something
truly cool about that I mean and it's
just basic stuff in a way just Bayes
theorem whatever but that's really
elegantly I think that the one had I've
got a fixed theta for all the time an X
1 X 2 xn our ID from plus and theta 1
and the second case no just X 1 from
person 3 2 1 then draw another theta
which is influenced by X 1 and X 2 that
so that's kind of an interesting I think
observation on its own right but there's
a point to making this observation is
that I could start messing with this and
rather than doing this I could do
something a bit different
so in the back of Bayesian theory
Bernardo and Smith you invent the margin
like you'd of these things if I've got a
price on distribution with a camera
distributed parameter we can look at the
margin like this is the form is very
nice familiar form to those who do
Bayesian conjugate models and you can
think of this thing as actually it's
really nice you can think about this
joint distribution as obviously it has
to be the product of the predictive
distributions yeah right P of x1 up to
xn is P of x1 times P of x2 given x1 and
this is just joint it's just probability
theory and so these things come so
that's what that looks like I think of
as a product of n terms and they're just
all cancelling out all the time I'm just
just the predictive of one thing is the
denominator the previous seconds on so
all the time so you see this go up to I
minus 1 and I
so the next of the loop of microphone to
end these guys will just cancel out with
an ex this guy or cancel out with the
next one in the loop and so on so you
see they all just cancel out and I get a
very simple form for the marginal but
that's essentially what's going on if I
think about it from the predictive
distribution point of view and Dave
finesse is representative seshu theorem
means it has to be this way if I want to
have exchangeable observations within a
segment which is what I'm generally
thinking about things about and things
be my ID from some feet or theatres
drawn from a prior that day finest
representation theorem says if I want
exchangeable observations then that is
has to be the format it has to be this
structure is exactly what it has to be
like okay but I guess my point is what
if I don't want exchangeability what if
I know my models wrong I know the data
on exchange but I know say for example
there's some drift going on over time
some slow level of drift that I don't
really care about and I don't want to
bother modeling it I just want to absorb
in fact these data aren't exchangeable
I'm more yeah I'm looking for continuous
things rather than iid so I'm just yeah
I'm willing to sacrifice exchange
ability for model robustness as the
omens are making I think I'm more likely
to be like the previous observation I am
than one at the start of the segment
because I don't really believe it is iid
it's an under specified model so yeah we
can break this full conditioning so
example rather than doing the product of
the predictive distributions like I'm
supposed to up to y -1 from from one I
can think about defining an alternative
probability distribution on X 1 up to xn
which have index with K for a given
integer K as I'm defining it to be the
product of my croissant to end now of X
i given not excite -1 down to X 1 but
just for the last K I just actually
windowing to the last K okay and so I
can still write down what the margin
like it would be under this under this
formulation so if I have this K window
say actually I only really depend on the
last K rather than everything in the
segment I'm just like the last K things
okay then this would be my Marsh
that's great I could still write down
integrate our parameters I can still
write down the marginal I could for my
for my which has to be Messier but I can
write it down but I don't know what K
years I don't have it here and I'm
trying to be too specific about that so
I want to average this thing over some
prior Q on K for example thing I've
implemented in the work is geometric of
a geometric prior so if I essentially
I'm here at time T and I'm looking back
and saying it's a Bernoulli trial
looking back into the past they could
have been a change point with equal
probability at every step back from here
but truncated by where my inferred
change points are as so my change points
are going to take on that interpretation
yes I'm gently gonna hit the head of it
here so yeah my joint distributed my my
jog - we should have x1 up to xn for a
given prior measure Q which is going to
be just do geometric is n simply this
thing so it's going to sum over my
geometric distribution for K of these
things so I can write down the marginal
I could for a given Q this is discrete
says fine
and to go back to that point I was
making about the sequential thing you
know what I'm saying you know x1 up to
xn being iid from Prasanthi to wear
these with gamma and I said okay that's
a saber joining fee to one next one
theta two this is what this looks like
so it's a okay for the enth 1 v 2 n is
drawn not from J equals 1 to n minus 1
but from J equals n minus K so he had
constantly redrawing theater again but
theater based on the last K rather than
everything and averaging over K times
ethos sure that's exactly thing I don't
want to do I want to do something really
really simple but yeah exactly if I was
a proper time series guy and actually
wanted to learn the relations government
I could fit a separate Riemann model you
see but I'm thinking about doing this
over all different sorts of things I
want to count inside Burma I don't I
don't want to be going down that road
map as I should want to but I'm
interested in running really simple
models where I can integrate every
parameter out and just get marginal
ideas just
yeah yeah so that I guess that's the
point here is I want I'm trying to
didn't develop a generic changepoint
tool that just can deal for temporal
trends without any structural modeling
at all just just John but get robustness
so taking the very simple change more
models and tweaking them a bit so
they're more robust it's a very very
fair question yeah it's like the
opposite of what I want to do good or
bad yeah so I think that's the
interpretation of this site lease of
twisted modelers I'm looking at there
may have been a change point at any time
in the past where that time file is
acute this distribution Q my prior of
when I think the change one would have
been truncated by the chain points that
I do infer so if I fit for a given
fitted set of change points what I'm
saying is I'm looking back I think
there's a geometric prior of how long it
was since my last change point but there
definitely was one there that's kind of
how it goes
so therefore these things in my mind
sort of take on the interpretation of
definite change points there they've
really got into a lot they have to be
because I'm allowing some sort of
possibility that could have been a
change but anyway even within a segment
by this but this K so this is what it
looks like to simulate a really nice
place to start so this is a press on
camera again so these you can see the
gamma parameters I'm using here so a
very small out for and beta so K because
infinity that's just the normal model so
iid and I've got a single change when
all these Peaks I've got a single change
more than 200 hope iid data in each
segment that's what it looks like so
with an intensity drawn from a camera
with those bellies now I'm going to
change K to some different things so
this is what K was 10 looks like I'm
just drawing drawing from that model
okay equals 5 and K equals 1 and then if
you see you guys getting some sort of
temporal trend so this drawing from the
model gives me stuff with temperature
and that's what I want so it's a really
cheap naughty way of getting Templeton
without any modeling anything just
putting a geometric prior essentially is
what
and I'm now going to change the gamma
parameters and why is that the more I
make the larger I make these guys the
more they're ignoring the data anyway so
the more temporal variation the more
unlike drawing from the prior wall over
against the more tonal variation I'm
going to get so now I'm going to try
there you go so there's our idea again
but we've now a bigger alpha in a bigger
beta so well okay so that's K equals 1
with this a big girl from beta so you
can see there's all sorts of me I kind
of like this because you know this isn't
this is no way a record value this
change one there's no way I got all that
side if I was looking at this and the
change point analysis i assuming
exchangeability there's no way other fit
in a fitter change point here right it's
right in the heart and close enough to
the heart of what I've already seen that
there's just nothing to pick that point
out but there is this discontinuity and
so looking at the someone which they
accept attempt it's a temporal feature
then you find exists from the model so
obviously I'd find it that way and I do
and so to finish this is what this these
ideas look like when fitted to those
port 4 4 4 4 5 data that characterized
the one a cry attack so that's what I
got just by running Bayesian change ball
analysis on the count just looking just
at four four I was looking the present
treating them as price on where I end up
fitting change points is a it's just too
many where as I'm claiming this is a
more parsimonious representation of
what's happened to this initial boost
here and then just before they attack
this boost start happening again here
and again here it really jumped up was
on so my feeling is I really like this
green page to compare to this rate
picture but maybe that's because I'm
biased because I really like to work but
I'm called Metrobus change for analysis
so conclusions so what I mean trying to
argue us at Cisco methods provide a
framework for automating the detection
of a significant unusual cyber behavior
that can be formed at different scales
when you form a level 2 for graph
analysis
at each level resolution and models
would typically be under specified
choose the complex nature of both human
and automated network traffic so like
for example when I was looking at the
fishes GTS looking at the beaconing
stuff and remember both had their stuff
on the clock as I'm able to quantify
using chi-squared type things you know
the significance getting a p-value out
about the significant being compared to
a homogeneous Prasant process or no one
ever thinks that was an emotional person
versus going on any of this so that's a
terrible null model and so in underside
models but nonetheless it's a good
enough baseline null model the things
were so significantly different and more
significantly different they are from
that the more like beaconing they are so
even though I may not be using the most
perfect statistical models the
probability calculus is still giving me
a coherent scale for prioritizing the
most significant looking weakening
things even if the numbers themselves
aren't quite right so that's kind of the
argument I think so it gives me a
coherent scale but I'm not saying I
necessarily believe every single p-value
yes but for that reason much of our
future work should be concerned with
identifying the robust anomaly detection
methods through a combination of the
sort of a must probe us models I've been
championing at the end there trying to
sort of be a bit more open to saying
okay I think I probably misspecified
this and so if I want to be robust and
more importantly combining evidence
doing data fusion combining areas from
different tests from different data sets
and so on so that I can synthesize
multiple weak signals into a strong
signal so that if I combine my bust miss
which also that's weaken my signal if I
can then combine lots of things I can
still get strength again so it's just a
list of a few papers I mention but
thanks your time
[Applause]
yeah I'm not sure if I'm pregnant that
when you compensated for not taking into
account this analysis by taking the
generating the new lung that's from the
previous for the thing at the very end
okay from the last K things where K is
online yeah it's okay has some that
primary so under the net for starters II
I think it's gonna be a difficult
question to answer but as you go from
organization to organization you have
any sense of like how much were you
tuning and read tweaking you know not
Los Alamos is is one thing you went to a
different National Lab at a slightly
different scale or something that it was
you know had different geographical
locations how we possible is most of
them well why don't you find in here so
in terms of findings I don't have any
mucho should probably way better
position than me to answer a question
like that certain the tools we're
developing should be a sort of situation
independent they should be useful in any
of those situations how much beating
there would be in someone in different
organization would vary of course but um
I think any of the tools we're looking
at should have a general general purpose
use but the findings across
organizations that's why I want more
collaborators they'd be great to do
somewhere with Microsoft though you do
most often hi space I know but um yeah
we need more collaborations that we're
really good to see how these things vary
between it's not easy to share these
sorts of data we don't learn alot very
unusual and publishing these sorts of
data we don't have other open data it's
all just academic so we have to work
with
[Music]
you do your fisheries G test thing like
way back to the beginning how did you
pick a sequence of of K values to test
so it's just driven by how many time
points I've gotten so the fast Fourier
transform just naturally spits out the
pirata grandpa for all F in that range
one up to floor of T over 2 where T is a
number of time points I've observed so
I'm not in any way an expert on the
mechanics of the fast Fourier transform
but I know there's an efficient
algorithm which throws out s of F for
all those frequencies simultaneously
really easily much more easy much easier
than doing them one at a time so I don't
choose it it's what the algorithm
automatically spits out and it's great
it's really fast that test statistic you
know like a some yeah yeah yes so these
are the Fourier frequencies that's what
they are
these guys are leasing t so those are
the ones this if you if you ask your
favorite programming language to do the
FFT it will calculate this thing for
these frequencies that's just what it
will return so no there's no choice for
mind is I just get those for free
without any effort it's super fast like
when you were modeling like you like
widely heard like traffic reserved
how are you filtering out like the
automated traffic like we were like
beforehand where you already like
determinant using my method like where
what what frequencies like the automated
traffic was occurring and then I'm
filtering it out and then doing that
analysis work right yeah so say for this
stuff there we're looking at edges which
we've already to determine from those
other analyses to be human ones or the
idea is that we would do a filtering
step and perhaps so it's all work that
needs to be sort of pieced together so
there are links where it can also join
together so if we if we believe this
sort of stuff where I can classify every
single event as being human or automated
then I could take that filtered human
data and fit these models on that so
that's the idea
but for the examples were using this
paper I think we're using pages which
because there's that nicely about doing
the Imperial stuff is with stuff on my
computer and we kind of know the things
so we go that's a human one with the
other between them so there's a way like
I I mean like there's there should be a
way about you being able to know
beforehand like what polling things were
going on yes so you mentioned Laius
right here that the Poisson process is
the pretty core model for modeling like
human behavior yes on a network so when
you're looking at the adjacency matrix
or like the entire network flow is there
a reason why you just use a Poisson
process there because I'm assuming like
a traffic flow is a combination of human
and automated so could you like add
place on process in a wall process there
tomorrow sorry I'm putting it so um this
this part here is like a motions parsing
process so this is like overlay of a
homogeneous person process with boosts
that's exactly what's going on there's a
constant intensity so yeah it's like as
I saying
I've got how much as processors except
I'm going to throw down some more points
on top from this boost of self
excitation these citations represent the
natural burstiness that we observe in
the data so it's somewhat artificial
contrast in the sense it's not it's not
like each event is trigger though I
could be I suppose in terms of firing
off ads or so on so there's maybe that
could be a sense where it could actually
be physically happening but um it's more
just a way of trying to mathematically
represent these bursts that we get by
saying if I see an event and I feel
there's more like a more like to see an
event now in this next instant and I was
before I had that initial wanting to get
the secret started you're doing the the
network well looking at the entire net
worth encoding that meninges
to make sure I'm sorry you owe me and
each entry is just cosine fo for the
present factorization stuff yes yes we
see her good point yes sir we'll have
some fairly inflated counts in that so
that's yes it's a very fair point so
yeah I can't remember that I wasn't the
person who actually did do the actual
analysis for that so I don't know if any
treatment was done in terms of
truncating the date at all and then he
was factory out seasonality they were of
automated stuff they may have been there
may have been some pre-processing going
on a little not sure it's a very good
point we should do that is they joining
these bits the others that have been
there often so it drops by the wayside
it'll work on these individual projects
with their knowledge they should sort of
fit together but and actually sort of
gets done I don't know
other questions let's sit Oh James yes
no let's thank our speaker
[Applause]